good morning good afternoon
and hello everyone and welcome to
today's live broadcast
clinical utility of extended genotyping
i'm alexis krauss of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths and
sponsored by
bd for more information about our
sponsor
please visit their website at bd.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr thomas wright
board certified in anatomic pathology
professor emeritus of
pathology and cell biology at columbia
university
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr wright you
may now begin
your presentation
thank you so much for that introduction
i'm tom wright and i'm going to speak
on the clinical utility of extended
genotyping
by way of disclosures i am a consultant
and pathologist for
hpv vaccine and diagnostic trials for bd
roche and inovio and i'm a speaker for
roche
and bd the unclarity trial which i'm
going to present on today
was sponsored by bd
i think many of you are aware of how
the bd on clarity hpv assay
is designed but for those of you who
aren't
it is a three well multiplex pcr
test with genotype specific primers
and probes with the e6 and e7
target now the first well
will identify hpv 16 18
and 45 individually
and it also has an internal control
the second well we'll identify hpv 33
and 58
as a pair so we know a patient if
they're positive for 3358
has one or the other but we don't know
which one
it also identifies hpv 31 individually
and then 56 59 and 66
as a group each of the
pcr wells has got an internal control
the third well identifies hpv 51
52 as well as 35 39
and 68 as a combined
grouping now there are a number of
reasons
to consider using extended genotyping
in clinical practice the first is
is that the risk for high grade disease
sin three or greater
varies greatly for different high-risk
genotypes
the second reason is that the risk
associated with type specific
persistence
is much greater than the risk associated
with a new
genotype infection and at the end
of this symposium i am going to show you
some data from the unclarity trial
which shows that this is true although
we've known it for a number of years
and the final reason to consider
extended hpv genotyping
is that the 2019 asccp
management guidelines are now risk
based and this is an important change
in how we develop clinical guidelines
rather than talking about how you manage
a specific group of test results
we are now saying how do you manage a
specific
level of risk and i'll also get into
that
later on in this presentation
this is a very recent meta-analysis
which shows the risk of sin three or
greater
over time with extended genotyping
there are a number of studies which were
have been done
these have included up to 14 years of
follow-up
if we look at the first insert
which is for hpv-6 state
what we see is that the risk of sin
three or greater
at baseline visit is quite high it's
over 10
and with time it increases
for hpv 31 the risk is lower
at baseline it is under 10 percent
but just like the risk associated with
hpv 16
the risk of sin 3 or greater in women
with hpv 31
increases over time and a very
similar pattern is seen with hpv
18.
this panel shows hpv 33 and 58
hpv 52 and hpv 45.
you can see that hpv 33 and 58
looks similar to what we saw on the
preceding slide for hpv 31
and hpv 18. risk starts off
lower than what we see in
with hpv 16 but it increases
over a 14 year period of time
hpv 52 and 45
have a less of a slope to their lines
which means that risk increases less
than it does for 33 and 58
certainly much less than what we see
with 16
and less than what we see with 18 and
31.
finally we come to lower risk genotypes
hpv 35 39 and 68
combined as a group in the dd assay
start off with low risk and risk remains
relatively low
even out through 14 years
hpv 51 is similar but with even lower
risk
and 56 59 and 66
show the lowest risk of any of the
groupings of genotype
there are a number of potential
situations
where the clinical use of extended
genotyping might be useful
one is with co-testing that is screening
women using both cytology
and hpv when one is performing
co-testing
we might want to use extended genotyping
manage hpv-positive women with negative
psychology
we already use in clinical guidelines
genotyping for
1618 in this situation
but with extended genotyping we would
look at the
other genotypes in addition to 16
and 18. similarly
when we're co-testing we might find
the extended genotyping is useful for
managing
hpv-positive women who have an assist
or a low-cell result currently we don't
use
genotyping when managing hpv positive
women with ask us
but it may be with extended genotyping
we will be able to find clinical benefit
for those who are still screening using
psychology only
one could potentially see using extended
genotyping
just like i mentioned before with
co-testing
in managing women with ascos and low
cell
for hpv primary screening we currently
use
genotyping for 16 18
and 45 for managing hpv positive women
but it's possible we're going to find
benefit
using extended genotyping in addition to
16 18
and possibly 45
and finally when we're doing either
co-testing
or hpv primary screening extended
genotyping
might be very useful in managing
hpv-positive women
at the one-year follow-up visit
in this situation we are thinking about
using extended genotyping
to look to see whether or not a woman
has type specific persistence
of her hpv genotype and i'm going to
show data
from the unclarity trial on how this
particular use is quite important
so i've talked about the unclarity
trials
mentioned it a couple of times what is
it
well it's a trial which we enrolled
patients from 31 sites
we did in recruitment over a two-year
period
2013 to 2015.
we then enrolled a subset of women
into a three-year longitudinal study
which just finished in march 2019.
in the trial we use surepass for both
psychology
and on clarity hpv testing
at baseline any women who had an
abnormal pap
that vascus are greater or any who were
hpv positive
got referred to colposcopy
we also sent a five percent random
subset
of women who were negative psychology
and who were hpv negative to colposcopy
to allow us to do a verification bias
adjustment
overall we enrolled over 33 000 subjects
and over 6 000 had baseline colposcopy
and biopsies
we evaluated the risk of cin
by hpv status in this study
and the statistical methods that we used
was that baseline risk of disease by hpv
genotype
was analyzed using a multivariant
bayesian model the probability
that risk of disease from one genotype
was greater than risk from another
was derived using markov chain monte
carlo methods
and the reason we use the bayesian
multivariant model
is that allows intuitive treatment of
subjects
with multiple infections and multiple
infections are quite common in women
in the general population who have hpv
this slide shows you
the risk of having sin three or greater
in women 25 years and older who had
negative psychology
at their baseline visit so this is the
immediate risk
for sin three or greater and we have
stratified the risk
by the genotype in a hierarchical
manner if a woman has negative
psychology
film which is negative for
intraepithelial lesion or malignancy
and had any type of hpv her risk of sin
three or greater was 3.1
if she had hpv 16 her risk was 8.1
if she had hpv 31 but not
hpv 16 her risk was 7.5
women who had hpv 18 33 or 58
and 52 had a lower risk
than those women who had 16 and 31
and then women who had hpv 45
35 39 68 51
and finally 56 59 66
had much lower risks if you were hpv
negative
your risk was only 0.2 percent
now in 2019 the asccp
did their management guidelines based on
risk
and these are the management thresholds
which
they developed for different clinical
managements
you would do treatment or colposcopy
if a woman's immediate risk of sin three
or greater
was 25 to 59
you would do colposcopy if a woman's
immediate sin three or greater risk
is for the 24
they recommend retesting in one years
if the five year cumulative risk of sin
three
is 0.55 to less than
four percent so not the immediate risk
but the risk over a five-year period
similarly we would recommend
that women get retested in three years
if they have a risk between 0.15
and less than 0.55 percent
and finally retesting in five years
if their five-year risk is less than
0.15 percent so these are the risk
thresholds which are used for the
guidelines
now looking at the baseline data
of women's risk if they have negative
cytology
what we see is that the risk if they
have hpv-16
is high enough that they need colposcopy
it's between 4 and 24
the risk if they've got hpv 31
is high enough that they need colposcopy
but women who have hpv 18 their risk
actually does not fit into the risk band
used for immediate colonoscopy in the
unclarity study their risk
was 2.9 so that would suggest that they
need retesting at one year
however we know that women who have
hpv-18
are elevated risk for having
adenocarcinomas of the cervix
which are frequently missed with
cytology
and therefore guideline makers have
recommended
actually since 2008
that women who have hpv 18
get referred for immediate colposcopy
even if they have
negative psychology so this
is immediate risk in women with negative
cytology
let's turn now to the immediate risk
in women who have asked us for low cell
here you can see that if you have hpv 16
you've got a risk of 14.6
31 and 18 give a lower risk
they're quite similar 6.9 and 4.5
then when you look at 3358
52 45 women with either 35 39 or 68
or women with 51 they have a lower level
of risk
and women who have hpv 56 59 or 66
have a very low level of risk in this
study
it was actually zero percent uh
there were a huge number of women with
56 59 and 66
who had asked us or losing even though
we
enrolled over 33 000 women
so now let's see what the management
guidelines tells us
for women with ascus and low cell and
again
colposcopy is recommended if you have an
immediate risk of sin
3 or greater between 4 and 24
and clearly women who have any hpv
genotype
16 31 or 18
fall in the category that need immediate
colposcopy
so this is what we can say based on the
baseline results
from the unclarity trial
the bd on clarity trial had a three-year
follow-up phase
in this three-year follow-up phase all
women who underwent colposcopes
baseline as well as 10 of the women who
were enrolled who had not had colposcopy
who had negative cytology and who were
hpv
negative were eligible to be
enrolled into the follow-up phase
during year one and year two the women
came in
they had repeat cytology and hpv testing
but they were only referred to
colposcopy if they had
asked us or greater year three however
everyone who returned was referred to
colposcopy
with a biopsy and an ecc
we identified the cumulative incidence
rate
which we call cir these were calculated
using verification bias adjustment to
determine the three-year risk
of developing sin three or greater
based on hpv extended genotype
this slide shows the three-year
cumulative incidence rate
for sin three or greater for women with
negative
cytology and we've color coded it
to show you the risks bands
or the management
approaches 16
31 and 18 as i showed you previously
they all require coposcopy
based on their baseline risk
3358 52
45 35 39 and 68
and hpv 51. their risk falls
into the retest at one year ban
women who have 56 59 66
their risk is low enough that they can
return in three years for retesting
and if a woman has a negative cytology
and she's hpv negative
then her risk is low enough to send her
to five year follow-up
this shows you the same three-year
cumulative incidence rate now for women
with asca's
or low sil at their baseline visit
women with any hpv 16
31 and hpv 18
all require colposcopy because of their
immediate risks
of sensory or greater
when we look at follow-up though what we
see
is that women with hpv 52
they have a risk of over four percent
during a three-year period as do women
with 35
39 and 68 and women with hpv 51.
now the new asccp management guidelines
don't really tell us what we do with
patients who have a risk
of over four percent during
three years or five years of follow-up
but one assumes that these women
probably need colposcopy
based on their three-year cumulative
incidence rate
women with hpv 33 or 58
and 45 their wrist bands
are retest in one year
because they're greater than 0.55
and less than four percent and
interestingly
women with hpv 56 59 and 66
even though they have asked us in low
cell
they fall into the return in five-year
wristband
generally we talk about
for the genotypes three risk groupings
16 18 and 31 is the highest risk group
33 58 52 and 45
is kind of the second level of risk and
then a wristband three
which is a much lower risk so how can we
use
these wristbands in primary screening
well this is the interim us guideline
which i think most of you know
primary screening women 25 years and
older with hpv
if they're hpv positive and they've got
16 18
they go to colposcopy if they have 12
other
we do cytology triage and we only refer
them
to colposcopy if they have ascus or
greater
and if they have negative psychology
they get follow up
now previously i showed you how
important
hpv 31 is how it has
a risk almost as high as hpv 16
at baseline for sin three or greater
so what happens if we take this interim
guidance guideline
and we say in addition to 16 and 18
let's send individuals who got hpv 31
to colposcopy what will that do
the other 11 genotypes go on for
cytology triage
well what we see is that by adding 31
to the group of women who get immediate
colposcopy
we raise our sensitivity at baseline
from 72 percent to 80.7 percent
we do increase the number of coposcopies
slightly
but because we're identifying more cases
of high-grade disease
the number of culpos that are required
to identify a single case of sin three
or greater
is the same as what we get using
only 16 and 18 as immediate referral
so we improve sensitivity and we do not
make the strategy
less efficient
this is another way of looking
at the hpv primary screening algorithm
here we would take women in wristband 1
those with 16 18 and 31 and send them to
coposcopy
women with the other 11 genotypes would
get triage
via psychology and
we would send anyone who had greater
than low-cell result that's
predominantly hcl
or atypical glandular cells they would
get colposcopy
then if they have ascus or low cell on
their triage phytology
we would send any woman who has an hpv
genotype
in wristbands two or three onto
colposcopy
so this actually is the same algorithm
that we saw previously it's just been
rearranged a little bit
and it also sends every woman with hcl
onto coposcopy which we would do anyway
because they would be hpv-positive
what happens when we modify this
algorithm though
here we take these women with ascus
or low cell on their reflex cytology
and if they've got 33 58 52
or 45 wrist band 2
they get sent the coposcopy but if they
have one of those lower risk genotypes
35 39 68 or the other ones
and they've got ascus or losel we would
follow those women up
in one year so how does that perform
well what we see is that the baseline
visit
using primary with extended genotyping
so we send everybody with 31
and then if they've got ascus or low
cell and the low risk genotypes they get
followed up at one year
we really don't reduce
sensitivity it's about the same as if we
don't use extended genotyping
but we get a substantial reduction in
the number of copos
and the number of culprits required to
detect a single case of 73 or greater
now is reduced to 9.2 which is
considerably less
than 11.4 now this is baseline
however when we look at the performance
over three years of follow-up all
three of the strategies have the same
sensitivity
and the reason for that is obvious we
are doing repeat hpv testing at one year
and doing culpo if they're persistently
hpv positive
and that picks up the miscases of
disease from the baseline visit
it also increases substantially
the number of culpa's are performed and
when we look
at primary screening with 16 18 31
together with the extended genotyping
where women with ascots and low cell
and the lowest genotypes get followed up
a year
we actually see a substantial reduction
in the number of culpos which is because
some of these women
clear their hpv over the year
and when they come back they're hpv
negative and don't get sent on
to colposcopy so in conclusion
for women with negative cytology
if they have hpv 16 or 31 they have a
high risk for sin 3
and need colposcopy if they've got hpv
56
59 or 66 they have a low enough risk for
re-screening
that they can get re-screened at three
years for women with ask us low sil
if they've got 33 58 or 45
they have a low enough risk for sin
three or greater for repeat testing at
one year
and if they've got 56 59 or 66
they can be re-screened at three years
when we look at primary screening
clearly
i think hpv 31 should be included in the
group
referred to colposcopy immediately
one year follow-up of the low-risk
genotypes
who have asked us in losing does not
reduce sensitivity
but it does reduce the number of
colposcopies
and i think this clearly suggests that
extended genotyping
may play a role in risk-based management
guidelines
going forward
currently the bd on clarity assay
is fda approved for extended genotyping
the pma approval supplement includes
expansion
for genotype reporting beyond hpv 16 18
and
it includes all the genotypes which neon
clarity assay identifies
and unclarity is the only fda approved
assay
to identify individually and report on
these genotypes
i now want to turn to the final part of
the talk
which is evaluating hpv persistence
when we think about hpv persistence
there are four potential
outcomes which we want to look at
one is true genotype persistence
an example is a woman who has hpv 31 at
year 1 and the same hpv at year two so
she has type specific persistence
a second potential outcome is clearance
with the new genotype
for example you've got hpv 31 at one
year
but the following year you've cleared
hpv 31
but now you have hpv-18
we also have new infections where a
woman was hpv
negative at baseline but then at
year two she gets hpv 18
so she's a new 18 infection
and then finally we have true hpv
clearance
where a woman is hpv positive at year
one
and she becomes hpv negative the
following
year
this shows sin two or greater rates
by persistent status and this is during
three years of follow-up
genotype persistence so the same
genotype
over a one-year period each of these are
one-year intervals
and there are three of them over a
three-year period
35.1 percent of these women
developed centur-grader if we take women
where treatment was done and exclude
them
the risk is lower clearance with a new
genotype
8.4 percent develops into or greater
over the three-year period if you get a
new infection
so you were hpv negative and then you
become infected
your risk is seven percent so very
similar to what we see
with clearance with the new genotype
their risks are about the same
then if you get true clearance your risk
is only 0.5 percent
and no infection has a risk of 2.2
percent
the very different risk depending on how
you manage the hpv persistence
here we look at the change in cervical
disease status
from baseline to year three excluding
those women
who were treated women
with genotype persistence
79.7 percent maintain themselves
as sin one or less ten point
seven percent progress to developing sin
two or greater
and four point six percent maintain
their sin too
among women who have clearance with a
new genotype
91.1 percent maintain themselves as send
one or less
and only 6.6 progress
descend to or greater for those women
who were hpv negative and then developed
an hpv infection
93.4 percent maintained as sin
one or less 4.7 percent
develop progression to send two or
greater and
0.9 percent maintain themselves as sin
two
so once again clearance with the new
genotype
and development of a new infection all
have about the same risk of developing
sin two or greater women who truly clear
their hpv their risk of progressing to
sin to or greater is only 0.4
and those who have no infection have a
risk
of 0.3 percent so they're big
differences in development of high-grade
disease
depending on what type of persistence
a person is showing
this shows the cumulative risk of
developing sintu or greater
at year one or year three
for women with persistent infections by
which
genotype they have so if you have hpv-16
at year one the risk if you're
persistent
is 5.9 and at year three
your risk if you're persistent is 22.9
hpv 18 persistence at year one
7.9 percent and at year three
it's 18.4 percent
31 6.1
and 14.1 percent
and you can see for 45 and 33 and 58
the three-year risks drop a little bit
but the one-year risk
does not drop and the reason the
one-year risk doesn't drop as we are
excluding
those individuals who had disease at one
year
and got treated
in conclusion if a woman
is persistently hpv positive during
follow-up
about half of those women have
the same genotype so they are true
persistence
but almost half of them clear the
original genotype
and acquire a new genotype
risk with clearance and then a new
genotype
is similar to risk for women who were
prior hpv
negative and then develop a new
infection
and their risk is lower than those who
have
persistence of the same genotype or true
persistence
therefore management of these two groups
should differ
genotype specific true persistence these
women need
evaluation but women who have
clearance and develop a new genotype
potentially we can do continued
surveillance
depending on the genotype that develops
if it's in
16 that may not be the case but for most
genotypes it probably is the case
and the goal is to be able to reduce the
number of coposcopies
which we perform at year one we saw
earlier how there was a giant increase
in the colposcopies
due to apparent persistence of hpv at
year one
what this could do is reduce that and
improve clinical care
so in this seminar i've covered
a number of facts about extended
genotyping
i think it's clear that this can add
clinical benefit
to managing hpv-positive women
thank you very much
thank you dr wright for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started dr wright our first
question is
when do you anticipate extended
genotyping will be incorporated
into the asccp app
it's really hard to know when that will
actually get done
the beauty behind the app though
is that was designed specifically
to be able to allow new methodologies
which are used for screening or for
management
to get incorporated into it there are a
number of different technologies that
are being
looked at and it's likely that
in the near future i can't say whether
it's six months or a year
but certainly in that sort of time frame
i would expect it would be incorporated
wonderful thank you for that now is
there any race related
study of risk
there is are no race related
studies of risk with respect to hpv
genotype there some data
which suggests that there may be
differentials but the data
is really not very good and it's
only for 16 and 18. it doesn't extend
down
to the less common genotypes
such as 56 59 66 or
35 39 68 and the data is not really
that strong it's an important area
though and it should be looked at for
sure
now moving on to our next question does
clearance with new genotype
mean that they cleared one strain and
contracted a new strain
or does it mean that the original strain
mutated into a different strain
good question hpv
has variants of the given genotypes
for example the one which is looked at
the most extensively
is hpv-16 and when you
look at hpv-16 and you do whole
sequencing of the hpv genome
you find that there are lots of
different variants and some of those
variants
actually appear rather frequently
and are associated with varying risks of
different types of disease
there is one variant of an hpv-16
which appears more likely to be
associated with
adenocarcinomas of the cervix than other
variants of hpv-16
however in order to shift
from hpv-16 to an hpv-31 that would
require
a huge amount of modification of the
genome
and that doesn't really occur so what we
think
is occurring is a woman has hpv
31 she clears
it and then she gets re-infected with an
hpv
such as 52. that's one
possible explanation for this data
the other possible explanation is that
we have to remember
that many women have multiple
genotypes especially those who don't
have
cin3 or cancer and it is possible
that a woman at year one could have hpv
16 and 52
but 52 was expressed at a very low level
beneath
the cutoff of the pcr assay
and the following year hpv 16
is either cleared or expressed at a low
level that's not detected
but hpv 52 is being expressed a little
more robustly and therefore can be
picked up with the assay
so it could be one or the other
wonderful thank you so much for that
answer now dr wright
how does extended genotyping fit in with
the american cancer society's new
screening guidelines
uh the new screening guidelines
recommend primary hpv screening
beginning at age 25 and extending to age
65 with a number of caveats about the
age at which you cut off depending on
how many times you've been negative
but essentially it's primary screening
they do not go into the role
of extended genotyping
so with extended genotyping
as we looked at the algorithms it's
clear that you can use it for primary
screening and that appears to have
benefit but it's currently not in the
american cancer society's guidelines
thank you for that answer dr wright so
we do have time for a few more questions
and we want to thank our audience for
all these great questions coming in
um i do want to remind you that any
questions that we are unable to answer
today and those that come in during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by dr wright via the
email address that you provided
at the time of registration so please do
not hesitate to keep these questions
coming in
so dr wright let's move on to our next
question
the clearance of hpv could be due to a
low hpv count uh would this be a false
negative
i'm sorry could you repeat that again oh
absolutely so the clearance of hpv
could be due to a low hpv count
would this be a false negative
it would be right it would be a low hpv
viral load is one reason that you
may end up being hpv negative we see
this
not infrequently for those of you who
are cytopathologists and you get the hpv
results on your patients as you're
reviewing abnormal
paps you clearly see
women who are hpv positive
they'll go a year or two and be hpv
negative and then they become hpv
positive
and it's not infrequent and it's
believed that
many of these women simply are shedding
hpv
at relatively low
numbers of a low viral load uh
the good news is is that those women
with low viral loads
tend to be at low risk for developing
high-grade disease
is that a false negative of the assay
well i guess you could interpret it that
way
um it's also
she's hpv positive but with a low
load
now our next question how long does a
positive
hpv infected sample in a liquid-based
cytology preservative
be maintained to be positive
how long can it be maintained a lot of
that depends
on temperature and the way it is stored
certainly we are finding with archival
specimens
that with time and time being years
that they begin to get lower
viral loads but certainly for a number
of months
they are relatively
cape or over many months
you can get hpv out of them that is not
necessarily the way in which the package
inserts
reads they all have timelines but in
research studies
people go back to samples which are
three four years old
and tend to get the same results when
they test them with different tests
now doctor right if a woman is hpv
positive for multiple strains when
tested
will all of the strains be reported or
just the most prevalent
that is going to be determined by what
you request
your laboratory to do certainly with the
bd assay
you could get reported in the groupings
which i've shown you throughout this
talk
and that
would require you to request the lab
to report out those strains
they're not going to at least i it's new
it's hard to know what all the labs are
going to do
but i don't think a lot of labs are
going to report out routinely
all the different strains in an hpv
report
they'll probably report out hpv-positive
hpv-16 hpv-18
and if you request it tell you whether
or not a woman's got
31. and the other one which is quite
important
grouping is 56 59 66
because they're such low risk
now dr wright what is if you could
explain what is the full
meaning of hpv
i'm sorry what is the full
meaning of hpv uh
as far as what the letters stand for
it's human papilloma virus
wonderful thank you so much okay oh go
ahead
no i just i'm not sure that was what the
question meant
um if you are still in the if
um whoever entered in that question if
you are still in the audience please
feel free if there is another meaning
that you meant for that question please
feel free to go ahead and put it in the
in the q a box that way we could
that way we could be able to answer your
question a little bit more specifically
for you
um so dr wright let's move on to uh
to our next question will hpv
testing with extended genotyping be
available for patients to collect at
home
currently we do not have an approved
hpv test which can be collected at home
there are a number of groups working on
this
but there are no approved tests in the
united states
once tests begin to become approved
the question will be will the
manufacturers
feel that they should run a clinical
trial
to get that as an fda approved test
and for bd and the unclarity answer
on clarity assay i really don't have any
insight as to whether or not that will
happen
and what bd thinks about that
great thank you so much dr wright um so
it looks like we didn't get any
more clarification on that last question
um
so we'll go ahead and thank you so much
everyone for the questions that you have
brought in
um thank you again dr wright do you have
any final comments for our audience
i think so the
field of cervical cancer screening is
moving quite rapidly certainly
we now have primary hpv screening
listed as the primary way you should be
screening patients
the real issue is the number of
colposcopies
which is are generated both when you do
primary hpv screening
as well as when you do co-testing you
really
generate large numbers of colposcopies
not just at the baseline visit
but also on follow-up visits and the
real
goal over the next several years
is to develop methodologies such as
extended genotyping
which are going to allow us to identify
which women are at greatest risk
and get those women into colposcopy and
yet take
other women at low or risk and
let them go on to some form of follow-up
preferably extended follow-up at three
years
rather than at one year so i think
there's going to be a lot of
new data coming out a lot of new
methodologies
unfortunately things are going to become
more and more
confusing for most of us and that's why
the risk-based approach is so important
and why the asccp has moved on to that
approach
i'd like to thank everybody for tuning
in today and listening to this
presentation
and thank you very much
thank you dr wright and while you were
doing your final comments we actually
had one more question come in that we
would love to be able to ask you
um does the vaccine
create any mutation of clinically
significant strains of hpv
no there have been no reports
of new strains of hpv
secondary to the vaccine there has been
some data suggesting that we get
different vax different hpv
genotypes by prevalence in vaccinated
women but that's exactly what you would
expect
because 16 and 18 are reduced
dramatically in vaccinated women
as well as using the nanovalent vaccine
other genotypes are being reduced so
when you look at a cross section of a
population
you would expect to pick up these other
genotypes
more commonly but that does not mean
that
new genotypes are being developed
or that there's even replacement
of genotypes by a non-vaccine genotype
has not
been shown to be true in enough
studies that people accept it
thank you dr wright for squeezing that
last question in there for us
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by dr
wright via the contact information that
you provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr
wright for his time today his important
research
and we would also like to thank labberts
and our sponsor bd
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and until next time
bye-bye